tutti ragazzi di questo video sono fa vj
oggi siamo i nuovi do speciale siccome
natale ho deciso di fare uno speciale un
po particolare lo speciale un video che
è diverso da dai video soliti che faccio
quindi ho voluto fare un qualcosa di
particolare ma sono ricordate ragazzi ma
circa un mesetto fa in un blog che non
mi ricordo che avete scritto fa vi
risponde famiglia perché non fai un
video dove dici 19 curiosità che non
sappiamo su di te una vera
io ringrazio dio di avere 19 anni non
averne 80 perché sarebbe stato un
problema ho deciso di farla natale lega
perché come sapete a natale si sta
vicini tutti quanti in famiglia e
siccome vi ho sempre detto che per me
voi siete praticamente come una seconda
famiglia ha pensato di fare questo video
è stringere un pochettino di più il
rapporto che abbiamo tra di noi e quindi
ragazzi mi sembrava carino dire 19
curiosità su di me che magari non ve ne
frega un cazzo
però la mia ha detto questo ragazzine
che possa partire con 20 cose che non
sapete su di me ne faccio 20 ragazzi
perché mezzo al video metto una
curiosità che non è vera e stavo i
ragazzi scrivere nei commenti qual è
quella non per a secondo voi è la dirò
nel prossimo blog così vedo quanti
quanti di voi hanno azzeccato mentre
altre 19 ragazzi ovviamente sono vere
direi che possiamo cominciare numero uno
la prima volta mi sono iscritto a
youtube ragazzi è stato il 30 aprile del
2007 mi ricordo ancora la data precisa e
non aveva un canale di gaming nel nulla
però quello è stato il mio primo canale
su youtube in generale numero 2 sono
finanziate da circa due anni la mia
ragazza si chiama diletta e vive a
firenze io sono di torino ci sono
all'incirca 400 chilometri di distanza
tra noi e prendo il treno una volta ogni
due settimane per andare da lei e l'ho
fatto anche nei periodi scolastici
perché non riusciva a stare distante più
di tanto da lei nonostante la distanza
comunque che è un grandissimo ostacolo
noi due siamo felici
credo che questa sia la prova che due
persone se si vogliono veramente bene
non temo non è di stanza nei nulla siamo
siamo felici a distanza di due anni e
sono veramente contento di stare insieme
a lei numero tra all'incirca un annetto
fa mi sono fatto il buco all'orecchio
per l'orecchino sia un orecchino ragazzi
il problema è che me lo sono fatto
nell'orecchio sbagliato perché diciamo
ci sono i gay che si fanno orecchino a
destra e
una cosa che si dice in giro e questa
cosa io non la sapevo quindi vorrei
uccidere chi mi ha fatto l'orecchino
d'ambra fuoco iniziato a giocare ai
videogames all'età di quattro anni
sì quel ragazzo quel bambino quel
neonato che vedete nel video sono i ero
io
[Musica]
numero 5 nell'esame di stato che ho
fatto l'anno scorso per prendere il
diploma era il turno del ragazzo prima
di me poi toccava a me dare l'esame the
rope tesissimo c'era una professoressa
che faceva delle domande impossibili a
tutti quanti gli studenti a tutti e
avevamo tutti una paura matta di questa
qui mentre stava interrogando quello
prima di me sapi si alza si ferma
davanti a me mi guarda così e io li mi
stavo pagando addosso in maniera
incredibile tutti mi guardano così come
dire oddio che cos'è il fatto di strano
dopo che mi guarda per due secondi così
mi fa me lo faresti un autografo che la
mia figlia li sono scoppiato a ridere
sono scoppiati a ridere tutti ovviamente
un autografo glie l'ho fatto e guarda
caso sono stato promosso ma forse un
caso numero 6
il mio primo nickname in assoluto era
lori 600 56 un nick name da schifo
perché quando mi ero iscritto a youtube
nel 2007 per la prima volta siccome io
mi chiamo lorenzo avevo scritto un nome
tipo lori però ovviamente era già stato
preso e allora youtube mi aveva detto
perché non ti chiami il lori 600 56 un
numero completamente chinato a minchia
non si sa perché io ovviamente ho detto
ok poi mi sono chiamato anche favi kraft
perché giocava minecraft quindi favi
kraft dopo la fantasia di un ippopotamo
e infine vi sono chiamato fa vj che ne
che neanche utilizzo anche adesso numero
7 da piccolo guardavo casi un casino di
cartoni animati su cartoon network e mi
ricordo tra i miei preferiti c'erano
billy e mandy ed edd eddy era il mio
cartone forse in assoluto il preferito
guardavo anche le superchicche ma quello
forse non lo dovevo dire numero infinito
da piccolo guardavo un casino di horror
ma veramente tanti nonostante non mi
facessero dormire la notte perché avevo
una paura tremenda ma ma veramente tanto
anche perché io guardavo tipo lost che è
una serie tv che non è ora però già solo
per quello non dormivo quindi vi lascio
immaginare
ho passato tipo di 78 anni della mia
vita sveglio numero 9 a tempo libero
sono al launch pad che sarebbe questa
specie di strumento per fare musica
prevalentemente dubstep numero 10
all'età di 13 anni sono stato campione
regionale di freccette e vero giuro che
è vera non sto scherzando numero
rotolava di tutto quando sono
sovrappensiero mi faccia i riccioli nei
capelli tipo così
non so perché essa cosa da dc il primo
video in assoluto che ho caricato su
youtube era un video sui pesci del mio
acquario non so perché nel 2007 l'ho
fatto non so come si legge questo numero
il mio mese preferito e aprile il mio
numero preferito al 7 infatti sono nato
il 7 aprile 14 la notorietà vi mette un
po a disagio nel senso che quando mi
fermano le persone per strada ma che mi
dicono favi ti seguo tantissimo e si
fanno le foto magari li vedo che trovano
e mi dicono fargli fai la foto tu perché
io tremo e io tremo più di loro perché è
una cosa io sono una persona timidissima
anche se nei video ragazzi non si vede
io sono timi a una persona veramente
timida quindi c'è ad esempio quando i
miei compagni alle medie non lo sto
dicevano io voglio diventare una persona
riconosciuta una persona famosa una
persona io non ho mai avuto questo
desiderio nel senso è una conseguenza di
quello che faccio ma non è mai stata una
cosa non è stato un mio obiettivo
sono contentissimo di quel centro non
fraintendete io potessi vi abbraccerei
tutti è una cosa bellissima
sono al settimo cielo ogni volta che mi
riconoscete ogni volta che mi dite favi
sei grande e sono contentissimo e vi
ringrazio solo che come dire la
notorietà non non mi appartiene come
persona non sono uno che si vanta di
queste cose perché non mi interessa cioè
banane 15 ho praticato un casino gli
sport da quando ero piccolo quali calcio
tennis il nuoto fatto anche per quattro
anni noto un casino di sport però
nessuno a livello agonistico
ho sempre desiderato fare un qualcosa
che rendesse orgoglioso mio padre io da
piccolo sempre giocato ai videogames
quindi non ha dato mai motivo a mio
padre di essere orgoglioso di me di
qualcosa poi quando ho iniziato ad avere
questo seguito su youtube
mio padre ho notato che è rimasto
veramente contento e quindi vi ringrazio
ragazzi per avermi dato la possibilità
di prendere orgoglioso mio padre di me è
una cosa che ha qui alla quale io tenevo
veramente tanto quindi grazie di cuore a
tutti questo è l'unico regalo di natale
che io avrei mai sperato di ricevere
l'unico veramente sexy il mio film
preferito di sempre a quello con il
vecchietto con
i palloncini e la mia saga preferita in
assoluto il signore degli anelli 17 ma
non a volte sec sisto 7 non ho alcun
animale domestico a parte i pesci che
avete visto perché quando ero piccolo
avevo un pesce di nome andrea non
chiedetemi perché ho chiamato un pesce
andrà proprio la pazzia lo teneva nella
classica boccetta quella dove si tengono
i pesci poi un giorno mia madre ha
deciso di cambiare l'acqua del pesce
quella della boccia ha ammesso il
pesciolino nel lavandino ovviamente
chiuso tappato così non cadeva giorno in
tubo ovviamente poi ha sbagliato ha
cliccato il tasto per farlo cadere giù
nel tubo infanzia rovinata e stato un
trauma perché io c'ero tipo
affezionatissimo e da lì non ho più
preso animali domestici ma ma che ti
dice questo che cos'è invece
18 oltre al servizio quello di mangiarsi
le unghie delle mani o non l'ho mai
avuto questo vizio però in compenso vi
tiro le pellicine delle labbra tipo così
l'unica persona al mondo a farlo 19 all
incirca 16 anni mi sono fatto crescere i
capelli perché volevo somigliare a el di
death note
però poi ho notato che somigliava più a
madonna quindi ho lasciato perle e come
ultimo la mia tesina per l'esame di
stato l'ho fatta sul fido quindi anche
su youtube perfetto ragazzi ha concluso
qui con le curiosità tra queste ce n'era
una di preciso che non non era vera avrà
tutte le altre sono assolutamente vere
spero che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi perché
un video un po diverso dal solito a
fatemi sapere qual è quella che vi ha
colpito di più di curiosità cosa che mi
ha colpito di meno oltre a quella che
pensate che sia finta e niente ragazzine
che posso concludere qui il video
ricordatevi che a natale siamo tutti più
buoni ma forti
quindi ragazzi buon natale a tutti buone
feste spero che il video vi sia piaciuto
come se i ragazzi se il video è piaciuto
lasciato momento mi piace anche a parte
di facebook e condivido trattano
descrizione forse dovresti di stranieri
ci vediamo non fossimo vito bello
ragazzi
[Musica]